[Music]
i came a long ways stayed on the ground
on them highways the other side would be
blessing them all
plays they ain't want me to make it
their coyotes hey it's money i can't let
the cow wait gotta make a big move in a
small place
the way i go i'll make the wild break
stacking paper i might need a tile safe
see i ain't gonna play i don't make me
away gotta carry my weight while they
call my back
try bro you stay that's a rookie mistake
i'ma [ __ ] up the brakes on my foot on
the gas can't worry about the nicks
instead they nigg
play like a chest i know i'm a legs i
only came and they beat for some care
move the wrong way and i'm dead on your
way smoking texts all over the place
all i did was put that in they face it's
amazing when i say a grace
i ain't following for they get to rape
hold it down cause it damn today
i don't been through more problems than
mace over time i don't know about a
break
take some paper till i feel it hey don't
give a [ __ ] i know negative feedback
died by my respect i'm beneath it i just
seen it and still don't believe it i'ma
hit out the door where you leave it
on the body show up where you sleeping
if the collar don't shoot where the
knees are have to put all that beef on
the meat wreck
when it's over you can't get a rematch
in this game it don't come with a
starter coat i wasn't slipping it [ __ ]
on the bar so
i was chasing that paper like cardio
what you got on the joe i could park a
phone they don't like me they really
don't hate me now
ever soak up the game like a paper towel
wearing that layer somebody town
pick up the place i don't play around
hey